[Music]
my name is Isabel Oscar Bono my nickname
is Izzy I'm 11 years old and I'm 410 I
think the strongest thing I have been
doing right now is my handling and my
passing my name is Brendan I am 33 years
old and I am 6 foot 3 my basketball
skill level comes and goes a little bit
played it when I was a kid but now that
I'm an adult
I've played basketball maybe like twice
in the last year one team Kobe's team
team Mamba Kobe's my coach he always
cracks us he's a cool coach I think this
child is going to destroy me here are
some things I am I'm old I'm slow my
knees hurt I doesn't matter I'm like
really small so I have to go through
like big guys big girls so I'm just like
being tough out there my height is
clearly my only advantage I have no
doubt that she's more skilled she's
gonna be faster it's gonna be really fun
I never gone against like a 6-3 guy my
goal is to be tall and be between her in
the basket as much as possible until my
ankles snap in half
[Music]
[Music]
Eddie our tents pretty good shouldn't
aim for like 10 but it ends pretty good
I don't normally make that percent of my
free throws so good job
I already miss as many as she has and
four free-throws in
ah come on
[Music]
what I miss like one two tops one I'm
honestly pretty proud to seven attend
that's better than my normal free-throw
percentage it's not quite eight of ten
so I feel like all things considered I
actually fared pretty well I like the
performance really surprising to watch I
think he's like a mid-range shooter you
know you made it like a couple of misses
but he picked it up by making more
surprised people every now and then with
my skill on the court you know I catch
people off-guard destroy people yeah
this is what I do it's not what I do
[Music]
we're gonna do dream behind it all
between wait that's all that so that's
one yeah that's
oh no between it's not gonna look that
cool when I do it yep got it Jake get it
up between oh yeah no I know what it
looks like when you do it no I'm not
ready or we're just gonna try to do as
many as we can without picking up
without picking up the dribble if I give
you $10 will you just like do two of
them and stop no great
[Music]
[Music]
here comes you ready I'm gonna learn
something all right she wins I lose that
one congratulations so that went very
poorly for me well done young person I
still don't fully understand what she's
doing and I've watched her do it a
hundred times she's very quick he's very
skilled props to you gratulations you
did great thank you
not my best event pretty hard it's kind
of a quick learner you know I had a show
them along the way so it was pretty cool
having a student to teach last event
we're actually gonna play one-on-one for
a little bit this is the only part of
this that I feel like I have any chance
to have any real edge on her I still am
terrified that her little quickness
she's me like darting through my legs
and stuff my goal be large stay between
this one in the basket and hope to not
embarrass myself too much I'm not
excited for this matchup I know that I'm
probably like smaller but a mental
toughness so I think I'm gonna be
[Music]
off to a good start oh no you're still
low to the ground
[Music]
you're very good at defense
[Music]
[Music]
my god like a shark attack
[Music]
I'm not even out of breath you're out of
breath it's scary when you back up
that's all
[Music]
[Music]
come on like a wild Mongoose
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good muscle just afraid of making you
angry yeah I'm trying I'm trying to work
the jumper a little bit like show where
I can shoot you it's not working
[Music]
I don't like the whole had a steam thing
I think I handled myself pretty well all
things considered
she's significantly better than me I
honestly thought I would fare better
down low but she got a lot of layups in
there which is a little bit embarrassing
but uh take a job he was really Thai
than me so it's a big surprise that I
eat yeah you kind of blocked my shots
but I just kept going kept going through
the scissor game I'm like it's okay that
he was blocking my shots you know I'm
not gonna get intimidated I'm really
impressed that you could drive on me as
much as you did I think it's cuz you
have a good attitude where you're not
gonna back down from anybody so hang on
to that I back down from lots of people
yours is better
[Music]